but first up he's a Pulitzer Prize
winning columnist for The New York Times
and it contributed to MSNBC please
welcome Brett Stevens okay so you last
time you were here we're working for The
Wall Street Journal a conservative paper
now you moved over to the New York Times
which is considered a liberal paper
which I must say I admire very much you
wanted to get out of your echo chamber
how's it going over there well I guess
it's too soon to tell I mean readers
take their views I mean I think what the
New York Times is trying to do is is
kind of extraordinary because I think
most people look to a show like yours or
an op-ed page like The Wall Street
Journal and they look for affirmations
they want their views affirmed and I
think The Times is making a conscious
effort to have an op-ed page which is
more like provocations use the readers
the writers you agree with to reinforce
your point of view but use the writers
you disagree with as like wedding stones
to sharpen your thinking and I think if
that I mean I think it's an experiment
but if it works I think democracy is in
better shape than than we realize in
common is that we both piss off liberals
now I do it because I think we both piss
off conservatives - I definitely pissed
off conservatives but that's that's
accepted that's baked into the cake the
pissing off no the pissing off the
Liberals I mean I think you're doing it
because you enjoy it I'm doing it
because I want them to clean up their
rough edges and and win again
I want the Liberals to win and I think
sometimes they're sabotaging themselves
yeah that's right I mean the problem is
that the question isn't how Trump won
the question is how did Hillary lose and
I don't think liberals ask themselves
that question
nearly hard enough Trump won because
they're all these deplorable what do you
think the liberal
biggest flaw is I think it's God why
could go down the list but look I'll
give you an example that will make you
feel uncomfortable but since we're here
why not I was last on the show January
2015 and so I was looking at the show
just to remind myself of how this works
and you had a segment about Joni Ernst
do you remember that no you should watch
it again because it practically explains
the 2016 election in that segment Joni
Ernst it turns out was so poor growing
up
okay well it's hang on hang on just what
I think I'm who Joni Ernst it the Iowa
Senator Iowa Senate Republican right
right one in twenty fourteen that's
right
okay and and she would put bread bags on
her feet as a child because she had one
pair of shoes so she says so she says
let's assume she's telling the truth
and so you mocked her for it and it was
funny
thank you it was funny to the people in
your studio audience ask yourself if
you're in Iowa or maybe outside of
Madison Wisconsin or in the middle of
Pennsylvania
Oh [ __ ] sake you're telling me that
brag bags on the feet is off limits for
a comedian make red bags making fun of
the poverty in which someone like Joni
Ernst grew up see now you sound like a
liberal this is what I get on the
Liberals case cool
you little smoke like bread this is
snowflake ism you can't take a joke
about bread bags on your feet look you
asked me why what is it about liberals
that people don't like and I would say
the answer is the answer is
condescension cultural condescension yes
well that I mean that's part of it but
but you know I went through this with si
si si si SE Cupp was here last week and
she was you know you don't call people
stupid and I I don't want to but like if
you like I don't but like over a third
of Americans don't know that Obamacare
is the same thing as the Affordable Care
Act that's your own health if you don't
know how to take care of your own health
as an issue what word would you use well
look I mean we have a serious problem
with like a politically educated public
and this is one of the reasons I think
we ended up with a guy like Donald Trump
and that people could be bamboozled and
sold on I guess I can say this on this
show [ __ ] and and you could become
president for it that's that's a real
issue right you're not going to get that
through by simply making fun of the way
in which people are raised I know but
it's a come on
you really are stuck on the bread bags
okay I don't think anyone really takes
offense at that I really don't first of
all I don't think half the people
believe it's true
I mean bread bags on your feet what is
the point of that because you really
don't have shoes Joni Ernst has shoes
she had shoes give me a break okay so
you called Hillary Clinton now you're
not for Trump
so okay which you know but one at silver
lining for this whole thing is that we
found out that there are sane
Republicans left saying former
Republicans former Republicans you're
not a Republican yeah I have a hard time
calling myself a Republican I have a
hard time calling myself a Democrat
[Applause]
but you say you know you you refer to
Hillary as a survivable event you voted
for Hillary yeah I did
and you know and I think that's the
natural thing to do and they're so funny
because I call that's what I call Mike
Pence you know right
I get very mad at liberals when they say
Mike Pence would be worse he would not
be worse that's a survivable event will
we ever get back to a place where we
think of each other as something above a
survivable event yeah you know I mean
the reason I said that is that I mean
you have to accept my perspective as a
right-of-center person who was never
sympathetic to Hillary's policies but
the way I saw the election was the
difference between risk and uncertainty
if you're a finance person if you see
something that's a risk you can price it
you kind of know what's coming
Donald Trump was uncertainty you
couldn't price him you didn't know from
one day to the next what you were gonna
get and that's actually the the reality
we've been in for the last six months
are we gonna have war with North Korea
or not are we going to deport the
dreamers or are we going to take them in
and it's I think that he says both in
the same sentence yeah I mean earlier
bipolars right this is this is not a
presidency this is a neurosis
[Applause]
well let me ask you this then I mean he
sprung from the soil of republicanism
could it have happened on the Democratic
side I don't think so I don't think you
could produce a Democratic Donald Trump
look you can because populism I mean
Donald Trump isn't just some sort of
accident of American politics he
represents a kind of trope in political
life and if you go back to the 1920s in
Europe or the 1950s and 60s in Latin
America you find people who are a lot
like him and they spring from both sides
politically these are the people who say
parliamentary democracies he wouldn't
answer racism
I mean racism is a big party but you
wouldn't have that on the left well you
have class hatred on the left that's
what you have with Maduro and that's not
a nearly as deep as racism okay I'm the
last one to make excuses what Trump is
doing right is culturally so corrosive
to the institutions of the presidency
that I really don't think he's
necessarily survivable no surviving
yes I want someone well all right let me
ask you at the last question about I
feel like his fans are not ideological
especially we found that out he can
pretty much go anywhere and they seemed
to follow him except the wall oh yeah
except for that one thing what is it
about the wall why is that I got to get
back to Kansas for them you know I asked
myself I grew up in Mexico cities I
speak fluent Spanish and and I think
there's something so ugly about
everything that the wall represents the
idea that we aren't blessed by the fact
of having Mexico as our neighbor is
insane we should thank our lucky stars
every day it's more than that you know
my mother was a refugee she came to this
country with $7.00 and in the space of
the generation would she wear on her
feet and yet she had shoes I'll check
with her but it's nice to know that in
the space of a generation you go from
refugee to quote elite and that's what
this country ought to be about and
people who don't understand that and
want to build walls to the refugees to
the indigent to the people who are
desperate to come to this country
they're the ones who have no place in it
all right we're building bridges
[Applause]
what Stephens everybody